وزير الخارجية الأردني السابق هو
موشيه وانضم إلي من رجل كان
أيضًا أول سفير للأردن على الإطلاق في
إسرائيل وهو الآن مؤسسة كارنيغي
للسلام الدولي سيدي ، شكرًا
لك أو سمعت وزير الخارجية هناك
الذي أطلق الرصاصة الأخيرة وما إلى ذلك.  انظر إلى
أن الجميع
يعلم أن هذا أمر بشع
وأنه غير إنساني ، لكنهم يستمرون على
أي حال ،
لذا فإن سؤالًا بسيطًا حقًا ، من لديه
القدرة
على فرض وقف إطلاق النار على الطرفين
، سيحدث وقف إطلاق
النار سواء كان ذلك غدًا أو بعد
غد.
هناك العديد من الدول التي يمكن أن تساعد في
القيام بذلك مصر
الأردن الولايات المتحدة بالتأكيد
السؤال ليس
ما إذا كنا نحقق وقف إطلاق النار أم لا
هذه هي
الحرب الخامسة الرابعة على غزة في السنوات العشر
الماضية والسؤال هو ماذا سيحدث بعد ذلك هل يفعل
أي شخص.
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة لديها
الرغبة في تجاوز وقف إطلاق
النار وأنت تعلم معالجة الأسباب
الجذرية لذلك وهو الاحتلال الذي يريده
أي شخص
لوضع خطة جادة
لإنهاء الاحتلال أو لا أخشى أن هذا ليس هو
الحال ولذلك يركز الجميع على
وقف إطلاق النار اليوم
ولكن تعالوا تعرفون الأسبوع المقبل
سنعود مرة أخرى إلى نفس العمر.
القصة القصة الحقيقية هي
الاحتلال
جيد وهذا يجب أن يتوقف ولكننا
نعرف الإجابة على ذلك
لأننا كما قلت يا سيدي في
المحاولة الثالثة الرابعة والخامسة لهذا النوع من
المنحوتات والحروب وأنت تعرف أوسلو.
لقد ذهب
وذهب للتو وليس هناك رغبة في التعامل
معها على ما يبدو من قبل أي من
الطرفين ، وهذا هو السبب في أن الفلسطينيين
اليوم أخذوا الأمور
بأيديهم ، ووعد الفلسطينيون من خلال
اتفاقيات أوسلو
بما يلي-
مرت ثلاثون عاما على حل الدولة دون
أن تحدث واحدة ، وما حدث في هذه
الأثناء
بينما كان المجتمع الدولي
يبحث عن حل الدولتين
، كما تجاهل الانتهاكات الجسيمة
لحقوق الإنسان من قبل إسرائيل
على أمل أن  قبعة حل الدولتين ،
هل تعلم جعل السؤال الذي لم يحدث موضع نقاش
وما يحدث اليوم
هو أن الفلسطينيين لم يكونوا
أكثر توحيدًا ،
ليس فقط الفلسطينيين تحت
الاحتلال ولكن الفلسطينيين الذين هم
اليوم
مواطنون إسرائيليون بخير ولكن دعنا فقط
دعنا فقط نأخذ
هذا النوع من المظاهرات التي رأيناها
للفلسطينيين المسيرات حول العالم كيف
يترجمون
ذلك إلى رسالة للقيادة
سواء كان عباس أو ما إذا كان حماس
مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن الانتخابات قد تم
تأجيلها وأين هذه الرسالة
على الجبهة الفلسطينية ينقل نفسه
إلى تحول في
السياسة رسالة مفادها أن العالم يتغير
ريتشارد ،
أصبحت مسألة الحقوق
مركز الصدارة
ليس فقط في الأراضي المحتلة ولكن في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
هذه هي الرسالة التي
يوجهها الفلسطينيون
اليوم.  الفلسطينيون
لا ينتفضون ضد
الاحتلال فقط بل ينتفضون ضد
الممارسات الإسرائيلية  العديد ممن
تعرفهم المنظمات في جميع أنحاء العالم
قد وصفت الفصل
العنصري قبل خمس سنوات فقط
كان يعتبر الفصل العنصري في العالم من المحرمات على أي شخص قال إنه
سيتم اتهامه بمعاداة السامية اليوم.
إنها تقولها كارنيجي
اليوم هذا ما نحن عليه هو
ما سيتعين على المجتمع الدولي
التعامل معه
ولكن لا تزال لديك المشكلة قبل
أن تصل إلى هناك وأنا أعلم
أنك تسير في دوائر هنا
صدقني "  علمًا بأنك تعلم
أننا عدنا إلى حيث بدأنا ، فما زلت
تواجه نفس
مشكلة الإسرائيليين الذين يقولون إن حماس
تحمي
أسلحتها ومقاتليها
بالبشر والمستشفيات والأطفال
وعلى أي حال حتى يتوقفوا عن إلقاء تلك
الصواريخ
لا يمكن أن يكون هناك نقاش  التي أوافق عليها
تعيدنا إلى حيث
بدأنا بالطبع ،
فالمفاوضات جارية منذ 30 عامًا.
لم تكن مرتبطة بحرب
بين
حماس وإسرائيل  إنه ليس ثديًا لأن
لدينا عملية استمرت لمدة
30 عامًا دون التوصل إلى حل
، ولذا فأنت تعلم أنه من غير المجدي الاستمرار في
الحديث عن وقف إطلاق النار ومن
كما قال وزير خارجيتنا ، من أطلق
الطلقة الأخيرة و  من لم يفعل
ذلك ليس هذا هو المشكلة ، فأنا
متشائم بشأن
ما تعرفه عن المستقبل ، كل ما
أريد قوله
هو أن الفلسطينيين أنفسهم
اليوم من خلال وحدتهم
سوف يدفعون العالم
للاعتراف بأن حقوقهم الإنسانية
تم انتهاكها
ولن يكون ذلك قادرًا على الاستمرار إلى
أجل غير مسمى
يا سيدي ، لقد أرجعناك
عندما سنتحدث ، ستكون متفائلًا ولكننا
نتطلع إلى ذلك على الرغم من شكرًا جزيلاً لك
حقًا لانضمامك إلينا